James Comer was on Fox and Friends when
he said this I wrote it down it's been
very difficult to track the money and
the accounts and I think now we know why
when you think about the llc's that were
used when you think about the private
accounts and the personal accounts and
how money was interchanged through uh
various entities it's a hard thing to
track it's needle in a haystack kind of
stuff
but if the Republicans want to prove
their case
they they need to hold press conferences
like these because we've been waiting
for this for some time and there are
some reporters John Levine's one of them
from the New York Post John Levine has
studied the laptop
um all 15
000 elements in there maybe more maybe a
little less right and so when he hears
something that they mention at one point
he shot us a text and he said we knew
this a year ago well I I think when
you're trying to prove your case not
just legally but also publicly you have
to remind people about the evidence that
you believe you hold and that's why I
thought today was important for the
House Republicans who are trying to
figure out how they can get to the
bottom of this I still believe they have
got a long way to go
uh an LLC you're going to hear a lot
about that today and going into the
future it's called a limited liability
Corporation and you you can have one
today if you want Jessica just find a
unique name that hasn't been used
already uh in the state where you're
living and the reason people do that in
business is because they want their name
free and clear of the uh of being
mentioned with with the company they
want anonymity and essentially that's
what you get through whether it's the
skinny Atlas which is named after a
finger Lake in Upstate New York or the
oswega I think is the other Finger Lake
um those were two of the llc's that were
mentioned today but your Top Line
headlines are what you mentioned many of
the transactions happen when Joe Biden
was vice president he also said uh that
they can account income of more than 10
million dollars uh to which he said this
is not normal and there are more than 20
companies that they believe Biden family
members use to quote enrich themselves
these are all the allegations they laid
out Jim Jordan came out and talked about
a suspicious activity report it's known
as a Tsar in the industry and whenever a
certain transaction over a certain
amount of money sometimes it's five
thousand dollars uh happens anywhere
coming into the U.S or leaving the U.S
it raises one of these SARS and Jim
Jordan was quoted today as saying that
there are 170 SARS that covered nine
different members of the Biden family
now that's that's his allegation
um James Comer says they believe they
can prove that four different banks have
been used but they also think that there
are up to at least 12. is right around
the corner the FBI has a deadline to
comply with a subpoena to obtain another
document that is tied to a separate
story but running concurrently at the
same time this is what happens when you
win the majority in the house you run
the Committees and you can investigate
what you want to investigate that second
aspect with regard to the FBI ideas with
the 51 intelligence agents who signed
that letter saying that the hunter Biden
laptop was Russian disinformation three
weeks before the election of
2020. they put out a statement last
night that came from the White House
that basically shot a lot of this down
and they and they said Comer's committee
has found its way to the broadcast room
quite a bit making these allegations but
they contend that Comer has hidden
information I'm reading now from the
public to selectively leak and promote
his own hand-picked narratives as part
of his overall attack to launch the
personal attacks against the president
his family politics is tough stuff and
you're seeing that now now how much
further Comer can take this is something
we're going to have to wait and see
there will be another press conference
at some point I don't know if that's a
month from now three months six months
or a year but we will be waiting to see
whether or not they can follow up with
the news they gave today but as I was
watching the press conference today
we were the only Network that took it
CNN MSNBC did not and that tells me a
little bit about how those story that
story is going to be covered at least
for some time uh unless there are more
facts that are or whether or not the
reporters of the White House start to
ask questions that deal directly with
this my guess would be that the press
secretary would kick him to the side and
refer them to some sort of a lawyer that
represents the president or even Hunter
Biden
um
if the media
doesn't give the sunlight that a story
like this may require at some point if
not already today then you wonder how
many of the American people and the
voters will actually have access to the
story itself ask yourself that question
and whether or not that even enters
their mind I think about the Border
situation and what's happening down
there we've had a reporter on the border
every day for the last two and a half
years no other networks come close to
that coverage you can spin the dial on
your cable network so you can look for
all these stories
um but by and large we are the only ones
who are reporting on that what's the
impact on that on behalf of the viewer
which is in my view the voter
um
some people will be unaware
that the story is even happening and
that will have an influence and effect
on their vote clearly